everyone has different ways to you know
get motivated and
very similar to sherm i do the same
thing you know i hear all the stuff and
everything but it's just um
you can't you know you can't put that
all out there all the time it's just you
know you have to do with it what you
what you will and take for what it is
just
you know at the end of the day you gotta
go out there and play football
friday edition of pro football talk live
there's jimmy garoppolo from thursday
meeting with the media one of the
umpteen times that all the key players
for super bowl 54 will be talking to
reporters this is one of the only times
we'll hear from them in their usual city
they'll be heading to miami soon as will
we big cat is back and jimmy garoppolo
big cat you know it's it's amazing that
he's being criticized not for anything
he's done
but what he hasn't done because at some
point in the second half of the
divisional round of the playoffs kyle
shanahan realized why do we want to take
any chances of this guy throwing a bunch
of interceptions let's just run the ball
until they stop us and from the second
half of that game to all of the next
game they haven't been able to stop him
so why let him do anything that could
potentially screw up this quest to get
super bowl championship number six uh
mike thanks for having me i feel bad
that you're sick it's actually good that
you got sick before miami though get
that sick out of you but i agree with
everything you just said kyle shanahan i
loved his quote after the nfc
championship game because i truly do
believe that the 49ers could have passed
on the packers if they if they wanted to
but when you're running for eight yards
of carry why would you ever go off of
that and that's why i love kyle shanahan
that's why i think he's one of the best
coaches in the nfl why he's sitting at
the you know eve of a super bowl right
now because he takes what the defense
gives him and he knows that you know
this coaching thing sometimes guys
overthink it sometimes guys get a little
too ahead of themselves and they try to
be cute kyle shanahan knows that if one
thing is working it doesn't matter style
points it doesn't matter if jimmy
garoppolo threw the ball eight times you
know what matters getting to the super
bowl so i love that from kyle shanahan
and i don't think jimmy garoppolo
deserves any criticism for that if if it
was flipped and you know super bowl
sunday the chiefs say hey we're going to
you know load the box make sure that the
49ers can't run first of all they won't
be able to stop the run because 49ers
run game is that good but i i if i were
a 49er fan i would think jimmy garoppolo
has the ability to throw the ball 20 25
times if need be so i'm not taking this
as a knock on jimmy garoppolo i'm
actually saying it it's it's a plus for
kyle shanahan and how great he is as a
coach
you know he admits that he hears the
doubters now
he internalizes it more than others
would but he hears them and you want to
prove them wrong and
you have to wonder how he reacts if the
original game plan that gets distributed
to the players calls for run run run run
run if they keep running and if they
keep running effectively like they have
for the last six quarters like hey kyle
i'd like to kind of prove that i'm worth
my 27 and a half million per year
because that's going to be the next
question big cat if he has a bob greasy
super bowl where he throws the ball
between seven and 11 times and they win
at some point somebody's going to say
why are the la paying him so much money
when they don't need to use him
because they if they wanted to pass he
would be able and obviously the 49ers
offense is not built to go deep because
look at the weapons they have besides
george kittle it's not like they have
these incredible wide receivers i like
debo samuel i like emmanuel sanders but
they don't have guys that are stretching
the field that are taking the top off
the defense so this this offense is
built exactly for what they have been
doing
it's not a knock on jimmy garoppolo
jimmy garoppolo
i think can be that guy it's just that
he doesn't need to be asked to do it if
the uh run offense is as good as it has
been all season long so i i
of course in the competitor nature like
jimmy garoppolo is sitting there saying
i want to throw the ball i want to win
this game i want to have a big part in
winning it
but let me just remind you jimmy
garoppolo you have a lot of money you're
very very attractive you can win a super
bowl and oh yeah guess what bill
belichick loves you and bill belichick
saw something in you so i'm gonna say
that you probably have something as well
if bill belichick thinks you have
something and kyle shanahan thinks that
you should be a quarterback so your time
will come just be patient and win this
super bowl
but if there's anything to the idea that
the way garoppolo was playing against
the vikings where he could have had
three interceptions that all could have
slash
should have been caught by eric
kendricks he did get one of them the
vikings weren't able to do anything with
it they got a field goal to make it
14-10 at the half when they flipped the
switch in the second half to 16 straight
runs was kyle freaked out by this sense
this perception this possibility that
garoppolo was gonna have a hard time i
mean what made kyle shanahan decide to
run to set up the run to set up the run
to set up the run i mean how many times
do we see at some point play action gets
sprinkled in when you've got a defense
on its heels that's what's been
surprising to me that they have come and
look
kyle shanahan is brilliant enough to not
outsmart himself if i'm doing this and
it's working and you can't stop it why
would i stop doing it that's the
brilliance of it but at some point it
becomes glaring at some point you do say
why are we paying this guy so much money
i don't i do not care i honestly think
that this is like
this is where we're at with the nfl and
coaching that kyle shanahan doing
something that works repeatedly which
then means that he's not passing the
ball everyone is sitting there
scratching their head being like why
isn't he passing the ball what's wrong
with jimmy garoppolo i would love to
have a coach like this who says i'm
going to just do whatever it takes to
win i don't care about being some genius
i don't care about having the run past
balance i'm going to win and if they
can't stop the run
i will just keep running it down their
throat it's it's refreshing to be honest
with you so i'm looking at it a
completely different way than people
saying oh jimmy garoppolo you know they
don't trust him or he's not up to the
challenge i'm looking at it as kyle
shanahan
is great for what he is doing and it's
refreshing to see a coach just flat out
admit if you can't stop us this is vince
lombardi mike this is vince lombardi
they're just going to keep running the
same play over and over and over until
you stop it and guess what they probably
won't stop it
you said something earlier big cat that
caught my ear do you believe the chiefs
will be able to stop the 49ers running
game no i actually don't i i and of
course i think they will be better than
what the packers were because the
packers were a disgrace in that
department so i you know qualify stop
the running game give me a number to say
this is how they're going to stop the
running game i think obviously they did
a good job against derrick henry but
this is a different running attack this
is a different uh beast all together
derek henry
unbelievable run what he did in the
playoffs what he did in december was
fantastic i just think that much like
the days of kyle shanahan's father's
team you know the denver broncos they
can just throw someone out there and hit
the hit the you know hit the one cut and
get downhill and they'll beat you over
and over and over again and it's the
blocking more than anything than the you
know the running back so i do not think
they will be able to stop the run on
super bowl sunday maybe a little bit
better than the packers but stop it
absolutely not
and in that first highlight that we've
showed if you're watching on nbcs under
sky sports it was the third and eight
trap play that was called
that raheem moster took to the end zone
and for me big cat when i saw that right
game over it's seven nothing but it's
game over because it's not like you're
going to come up with some different
strategy at halftime that's going to
allow you
to stop what you just physically can't
stop and one of the things i've been
talking about this week
the fact that the 49ers have collected a
bunch of guys who are
badass roughneck we don't need to
practice blocking hitting and tackling
because they don't practice it like they
used to the 2011 cba reduced
dramatically the amount of time that
these guys can go out and get that
callus on their bodies as jim harbaugh
calls it sharpen the saw have yourself
ready for contact on sunday because
you're getting contact more frequently
these are guys who can flip the switch
at any time and they will go out there
and they will out hit outwork out muscle
and i think there's going to be a
premium placed you know where where
there's always a reaction to when a
great team
comes out and dominates the nfl what do
you do to stop him what do you do over
the next seven months how do you slow
down patrick holmes that was last year's
project this year it's going to be equal
parts what do you do about lamar jackson
and what do you do about this 49ers run
game well you know what you do you go
out and you find some guys who can
tackle without practicing tackling
because they don't who can hit without
practicing hitting because they don't
and until someone comes up with a
defense like that
i don't think you're gonna be able to
stop the 49ers running game
yeah i agree with you and one other
thing the uh if you if you look at the
advanced stats the chiefs were one of
the worst teams this year on defending
the run to the edges and that's what the
49ers do very very well they obviously
were good against derrick henry derrick
henry cut the ball back a lot and and
that kind of was you know the day for
for the titans and situational football
obviously matters where that uh drive
the titans have to you know with two and
a half minutes left in the first half
they go three and out the game kind of
flips it's harder to run the ball when
you're down against a team like the
chiefs against patrick mahomes i just
think the 49ers the way that they're set
up
they're they're going to be able to run
on anyone now i'm sure we'll get to this
and talk about it all next week that's
not saying that patrick holmes won't be
able to throw on the 49ers so this might
be a game because of that way but in
terms of the matchup where the the
chiefs defense matching up against 49ers
running attack i i do not i'm
hard-pressed to see the chiefs being
able to hold them to under 100 yards
like they did with derrick henry
big difference too that i see between
derek henry and the
running game that the 49ers have derek
henry needs two or three steps to get up
to full speed the 49ers don't they go
the acceleration and the burst are
immediate so you don't have the luxury
of a couple of steps to get to the guy
and try to hit him before he busts
through the hole and he's gone you got
to get there faster or he's going to
bust through the hole and he's going to
be gone and we see that very exotic
blocking that that chris sims breaks
down all the time and he does it
extremely well that shows how the
fullback and the tight end kyle yuschik
and greg kittle i mean george kittle get
involved and and uh create those holes
to get blown wide open and the guy's
gone before he can do anything about it
he's just gone
yeah it's it's fantastic to watch and
and that was actually a funny thing you
know on sunday everyone's saying where's
george kittle he only had i think one
catch well if you watch the game and
you're not watching the ball george
kittle's all over the field he's he's a
blocking maniac and he's the type of guy
that you love to have on offense because
he doesn't care if he gets the ball he
probably if you asked him he probably
enjoys blocking just as much as he
enjoys pass catching so having those
type of guys the dudes that can
basically make this whole machine run is
why the 49ers are in the subaru and why
their their rushing offense is special
yeah he said after the game how many
runs did we have they told him 42 he
said we should have gone for 50. and
they also have guys like debo samuel and
emmanuel sanders on board with two it
helps when you're winning see you can
get by with the 1973 miami dolphins
offense if you're winning but the moment
you're not winning that's when you start
to get the questions they they they
wanted to trade for odell beckham jr
back in february and march before he
went to cleveland how do you think odell
beckham jr would be dealing with this
run-heavy offense in the postseason well
probably not very well but mike you
bring up odell beckham and we you know
this whole super bowl week when we get
to miami it's going to be the patrick
mahomes week and it rightfully so he is
the most electric quarterback in the
game he is going to be the best
quarterback in the game for probably the
next decade but it's going to be
interesting how the narrative gets
written here with
you know the chiefs this is their first
super bowl of what should be many in the
next decade what about the 49ers the
49ers you just said they wanted odell
beckham 49ers don't have that deep
threat guess what guess what is a plenty
in this year's draft wide receivers
there are so many good wide receivers in
this year's nfl draft
can you imagine the 49ers adding a
special deep threat to this roster are
we saying to ourselves the the chiefs
are going to be back here every single
year and not realizing maybe it's the
49ers that are starting something
special maybe it's the 49ers that are
going to be back here every year and
this is the start of something that in
in five six years we look back on and
say wow kyle shanahan you know jimmy
garoppolo george kittle this whole
niners thing it's been working and
they've been to three four super bowls
you know it was funny after the nfc
championship aaron rodgers was speaking
in very optimistic terms even though he
looked miserable he looked like he just
got back from five months at sea he said
the window is open for us and we're
going to be on the right side of one of
these soon then a couple of days later
coach matt lafleur basically was like
how in the hell are we going to beat the
49ers i mean who's getting past the
49ers the way this team is currently
constructed the way they can run the
ball the way they play defense the way
they're coached week in and week out
it's going to be a big challenge for the
packers or any other team in the nfc
including your chicago bears i i wore
this today so you would be nice to me
you haven't you haven't given me a hard
time about it yet i don't know what
you're talking about mike this is when
it is when you like do the two for
flinching and i'm just not gonna tell
you when i'm gonna give you the shot in
the arm so i have no idea what you're
talking about i don't know if you were
trending yesterday i don't know if you
said anything controversial we'll just
have to find out if i get a joke in
somewhere along the way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports